this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
[Music]
light okay so let's
continue so welcome to the uh second
Central lecture uh this is lecture
two
manifolds
we talked about topological
spaces and it's a fact of life that
topological
spaces
um there are so
many that
mathematicians cannot even classify
them
that may be a statement that's a
function of
time but in fact there are many
topological Notions a house of space a
connected space a parac compact space or
a compact space and so on and if you
take all the Notions ever invented that
are topological Notions that are
properties of a topological space that
are defined in terms of the topology and
you make a big chart and you say this
set
has the notion has not the notion has
the notion has not the notion even
Notions that are not Boolean valued yes
or no it has the notion or not there are
Notions that are group valued and so on
so that is this group that is that group
you take this whole all the the Notions
and then you ask are there any two
topological sets that are not
homeomorphic so between which there
exists um not an invertible in both
directions uh continuous map which Maps
the topology one to one to the other
topology such that all the Notions uh
okay now got G so the question is can
you decide on just click ticking the
Notions or not whether the two spaces
are homeomorphic or not and the answer
is there is no such set known of
topological Notions that you could do
that so for any set you come up with
they are counter examples so they're not
classified um well okay that's a
mathematical problem uh a physical
problem is really that many sets that
you give a topology they resemble what
we think of SpaceTime so little uh that
they're not deemed at the moment they're
not deemed to be useful as models for
SpaceTime but there is a very special
type of topological spaces so I write
for SpaceTime physics classical
SpaceTime
physics we um May
Focus
again a statement that may be a function
of time uh we may focus on topological
spaces remember that's a pair of a set
and the chosen
topology that can be
charted that can be
charted
very or
analogously
to how the surface of the
Earth is
charted and if you buy many charts that
cover the surface of the Earth uh in an
atlas and an atlas and a chart you can
buy in a
shop
but you don't need to because we can
construct
them so this special
type of topological
spaces these are called
topological
manifolds so we start with the
definition
definition a topological
space m o so so so you got my my My
Philosophy here
I do a little bit of imprecise blah blah
blah in order to give you an idea but
then comes the Precision afterwards okay
and of course you in the future only
refer to the
Precision okay so a topological space m
o is
called a d
dimensional a d
dimensional
topological manifold and I already use
my favorite short cuts here top my
manifold topological
manifold if so there's a condition so a
topological manifold is a topological
space with an extra Condition it's this
charting condition it says that for
every point in the
set there
exists an open set u open with respect
to the topology o of course containing
the
point can say it's an open set around
the point exists an open set containing
the point such that there
exists a map
X from this region open set in the
manifold
into r
d and this D that features here
is the D that features
here to Rd such that now comes the
actual
condition um first of all such that X is
invert okay you see already ah so it
goes to Rd that's correct but of course
it doesn't need to be
subjective one could always make it
subjective but let's say it's not it
goes to the image
of the domain under the chart X and that
is supposed to lie in Rd okay such that
X is
invertible that means there is a map X
inverse that goes from the image back to
you okay it's the first condition the
second condition is that X is
continuous now you say aha
continuous you need to tell me what the
topology is on this set Ah that's not a
problem because this is a
subset of the entire manifold of the
entire topological space and this is an
open subset it's not a problem to
establish a topology here and here this
is a subset of Rd so on this m we of
course have the topology o and on this
Rd we choose because nothing else is
said we choose the standard
topology and with respect to those we
require X's continuous and then the
third condition is that the inverse of X
is also continuous and of course you
learned from the example in the last
lecture that if the a map is continuous
in one to one it still doesn't mean or
invertible it still doesn't mean that
the inverse is also continuous but
nevertheless here we require
it that's
it it's a very simple
definition yes pardon
me topology
orology so I take a set with a given
topology whatever it
is and this topological space is called
a topological manifold of Dimension D if
now it gets complicated for every point
of this set there exists an open set in
this topology whatever it is doesn't
need to be the standard topology and it
can't be because if m is not Rd I don't
even know how to define the standard
topology a some topology exists an open
set containing the point but there
exists not only such an open set but
there also exists together with this set
for every point there exists an entire
map so a lot of data whose existence I
require here there exists a map that
takes every point of the set around the
point to a subset of Rd in an invertible
one to one manner which in both
directions is continuous I will clarify
this of course but this is the
definition and now we'll fill this
definition and the elements of this
definition with some
life okay uh first thing we note if x is
invertible then the inverse of course
goes in that direction but then the
pre-images of open sets are open but
then the pre-image of u under X inverse
is of course X of U because this was
open this must be open so uh because
this is open and all of these conditions
apply we know that the image in Rd is
open what I will do now I will first
give you three examples that I simply
draw and will slowly pick up on the
elements of this and give them names
that are very familiar to you from
navigating maps on the surface of the
Earth if you're the captain of a ship
okay but I don't want to confound You by
uh well anyway so we do it like this so
examples so the first example I just
draw it and we talk about it and later
on you can you will be able to actually
calculate this so I take the surface of
a
donut but I just really mean the surface
of this guy so the surface of a car tire
okay and I claim that this surface this
set M donut
surface this is the set M yeah and um I
equipped this with some topology it may
inherit from the surrounding R3 because
I can put this tire into an R3 I can
Define it as a subset of R3 I can equip
R3 with the standard topology and I
inherit to M the subset topology but
this is not the standard topology this
is the subset topology that originally
comes from the standard topology for
instance or you prescribe one all by
yourself but let's take this one then
the claim is this
is a
two-dimensional
topological manifold I don't discuss
this technically but let's nevertheless
go through this
definition in order to be that it must
be true that for any point in the set so
I close my eyes and I blindly Mark a
point in the set on the surface for any
point in the set there exists an open
subset well we know how the open subsets
in the induced topology look like um
because they will look like this because
I could take an open set in the R3 that
looks like this without the boundary I
insect this with the car
tire and and what remains is this guy
without the boundary
clear because it's this U intersected s
so this is okay so I mean it's a quick
discussion but it's all true I'm saying
okay so for any point P and M there
exists a u that contains the point okay
yeah I found
one satisfied and there exists a map the
exists one I need to find some that
takes every point in the set
so this is the
U that takes every point in the set so
for instance this
one to some part of
R2 aha
so I take some R2 and I take this point
to say that one by this map X right this
is Map X but of course I take this point
here also to a point here
and if I take all the points in U to all
the points
here I get some open region in R2 why do
I know it's open well because of the
invertibility and the continuity in both
directions I I get
this and this is true and and so for
this arbitrary point I got this and it's
clear this works everywhere so I need a
one to one map and it needs to be
continuous and one can calculate this
and really prove there exist such maps
for this
example so this is very nice because
this is precisely what you would do if
this was not the Taurus if this was the
surface of the Earth you would take the
Earth and you would make charts and in
fact we have uh we'll introduce soon the
terminology that okay let me before we
introduce terminology let me talk about
physics this thing here let's consider
that to be the real
world let's say the the globe is not a a
sphere it's it's a Taurus could be and
this point here the little cross is the
foot of the Eiffel Tower I really mean
the foot of the Eiffel Tower the
physically existing foot of the Eiffel
Tower that's a point in the real world
you can go there and touch it the foot
of the Eiffel Tower now what I do here I
construct a map and I have posited the
existence of a map that Maps this
situation and the foot of the Eiffel
Tower into an element of
R2 but R2 is R cross R is simply a set
of pairs of real
numbers of course I could have chosen a
totally different map into r2ol where
the foot and here the foot of the AL
because this is R2 we like to say it has
components uh one two but anyway uh you
could have chosen a totally different
map of this and then the image of the
foot of the Eiffel Tower this is X of P
if p is this point the foot of the I
Tower X of P has two parts it has X1 of
p and X2 of P this case turn out to be
one and
two by choosing such a map you can say
oh the Eiffel Tower is
at12 but it means nothing Well it means
something because you chose a specific
map so you go to a shop and you buy an
atlas and you go to page 27 and this
here this R2 a part of R2 is Page 27 of
the
atlas and then you start and then you
look and you say oh there's the Eiffel
Tower and here's Munich and so on okay
and you say oh my God the Eiffel Tower
is at one two that must mean something
well of course it means nothing it's
just one cimeter from the lower edge of
the of the chart to here because the
publisher decided to choose the chart
like this if the publisher had decided
to choose the chart like this or to
distort the chart so the publisher uh
has a a rubber paper and distorts the
chart and so on things look
different physical meaning nil nothing
but the foot of the Eiffel Towers in the
real world and we like to represent the
real world by coordinates in a chart and
in fact well I introduced the
terminology at this point so terminology
pce
Oney a pair uux and remember X is not
the coordinates or something X is a map
taking all these points into Rd is
called a chart so a chart consists of
the domain of the chart in the real
world U could be the area of Paris
I mean the area of Paris in the real
world that is the area of Paris that you
can go and
touch X of U is the image of the area of
Paris in the chart so this
here no it is the one I I I already
shaded here this whole image here this
is Paris how it appears on paper you can
also touch it but you touch the paper of
the atlas right real world paper of the
atlas the connection is what the
publisher decided to choose as the
connection between the two it's a choice
the publisher also decides whether he
takes all of Paris with or without the
Bon Le year and so on okay this is a
chart and all you require is that for
every point of the
manifold there exists a chart that
contains the
point every around every point of the
the whole whole manifold is covered by
charts that is what this definition says
so if you go to a shop and you buy a
chart and your hometown is not on it you
return the atlas to the shop and you say
I feel cheated there are many charts in
there but not the one I
like you can make sure if for every
point there exists such a pair ux with
these properties that your little
Hometown is on
there okay so anyway uh
I already introduced terminology in the
context of this example although I
didn't want to but it doesn't matter um
second
example
um I take a wire and it's not
disconnected here it's just behind it's
it's an eight figure eight distorted why
like this you can also imagine this
lying in some R3 you can again take the
standard topology on R3 inherit it to
here and then have here the topology on
the the topology the standard topology
here restricted to the set M so by this
wire the points of this wire are the
points M the claim is this is a
1dimensional
topological
manifold how do the charts look like
well for every point that exists an
open set u in the real world every point
in in the real world on the manifold
level there exists such a domain around
it such that every point of the domain
is mapped one to one to some part of R
could also be disconnected or not but
roughly like this so the charts are just
one dimensional well because it's a
onedimensional
world okay one dimension less this is
more intuitive to us although it's one
dimension higher but nevertheless this
is
that uh third example
um you have something like
this and then it bifes it's also a set
set M it's clearly a subset for instance
of R2 right cons can consider it like
this you can certainly on R2 consider
the standard topology on R2 and you can
inherit the standard topology to the
subset because m is a subset of this
space so it clearly carries a topology
so C for instance M equipped with the
standard topology on the surrounding
space on the super space restricted to M
you can do this and this is a
topological space all right topological
space but it fails to be a topological
manifold but
fails to be
topological manifold well let's
investigate this in detail
investigate the
problem well I reproduced this at this
point there's not a problem I need to
check whether for every Point say this
one there exists an open set around it
in the IND used topology like this one
because you see in the R3 this would for
instance be open the intersection is
this and so on okay exist an open set
and certainly you can hear you can make
a map of this bit of course also for
this point there's not a problem also
for this point there is not a problem
but this guy here this makes the problem
because for this guy
here it is not possible to find a
neighborhood an open neighborhood which
for instance we can find an open
neighborhood for instance by taking an
open set in R2 and then the subset
topology would say that for instance
this blue set
here is open in the subset topology very
clear so there's not a problem to find
around this point there is not the
problem to find an open
set what you will not be able to do is
to find from this blue open set an
invertible in both directions continuous
map into either R1 or
R2 because here it Bates well needs to
to work a little to I mean intuitively
one sees it what how would you chart
this right in fact you can't in fact you
can't so this is not this is not a well
question mark
dimensional topological
manifold okay so it's very easy to come
up with stuff that is not a topological
manifold or maybe string theorists uh
they like to think of De brains and
little strings attached to them and
stuff this total configuration is not a
topological manifold could also say here
it is onedimensional and here it's two
dimensional but the definition requires
there is one D that applies everywhere
and you might say oh couldn't we loosen
this and have a more interesting notion
well it still wouldn't solve the problem
what to do about this point where they
start touching you get a similar problem
like in the
bipoc
uh just this openness does this really
on this level that it's
like because I for Simplicity I needed
to not only give you a set I needed to
give you a topology on the set in order
to have a topological space in order to
then be able to decide whether it's a
special topological space I topological
manifold I had to provide you with some
top apology because it serves our
intuition for this quick drawn arguments
without calculating best if I use the
standard topology which you know
intuitively and pull them back because I
know I have to do these intersections I
use this specific standard topology on
the surrounding space because I need to
say anyway what the topology is and then
it's right if you then have a line and
uh and then you ask what are open around
this you could take any open set so say
you take a line a subset in R2 equipped
with the standard topology I can take
any open set in R2 for
example all these points in the Shaded
area together are one open set because
for every point in this open set I find
a little soft ball that lies entirely in
it and so on this is an open set and
this open set intersects
with the subset sorry intersected with
the
subset gives these two open intervals
but they're not intervals because this
is not the real line This is already the
subset gives what looks like two open
intervals so in in that sense yes uh if
you come from the standard topology it
looks like oh we already knew this was
open or not but the real argument is by
the subset topology which again I only
used in order to quickly draw pictures
using your intuition about open sets in
R2 okay
good here yeah well well two dimensional
one looks like this for instance no but
the second example we also live in R3
yes and then you say okay this is a
onedimensional topological manifold yes
but why is it a onedimensional could I
have two
Dimension there is no continuous map
from this U from this set u into
R2 you cannot do
that you can construct uh uh um I think
you can
construct a bjective map into R2 that's
already difficult because you have to to
wind the interval like this I'm not
entirely sure I think that's somehow
possible but certainly not a continuous
one that's the
point okay so that's I mean yes yeah
that's the point so the it um it would
fail this year if you increase the D to
two Okay I'm not claiming I mean this is
very intuitive and I want to give you an
impression and you need to trust me that
it's all true which I do hand waving but
it's good to First have this impression
but we'll go to specific examples and
calculate this also in the tutorials
today okay but first to have an
impression of the Notions is important
okay so um now
come uh comes a lot of terminology but
very good
terminology
terminology we already had the chart so
I'm always referring to the objects in
the definition and so uxx where U and X
have the properties from the definition
are a chart of the topological manifold
M Mo okay and the definition requires
that around every point there is such a
chart and as I said that is what a
publisher needs to make sure if he sells
you an atlas that satisfies you a set
a that contains a collection of charts
so let's call them U alpha x Alpha so
Alpha is now a label you have many many
sets U many many sets X this label can
come from any arbitrary index set so
have a huge possibly a huge amount of
charts such a collection is called an
atlas well it's very intuitive a
collection of charts is an atlas if
there's only one condition that if you
take the union of all the chart domains
remember this chart domain is Paris the
real area of Paris in the real world X
of you can then reconstruct the images
of Paris
but if all the areas that are covered by
the chart if you take them all together
they may have huge overlap but if you
take them all together you should
recover the entire real world so every
piece of the real world should be
covered and then you call a collection
of charts an atlas of the
world it's a very important notion so
this is an atlas of the topological
manifold if this is true very
intuitive
okay that was that now a further piece
is
called this x that goes from U from the
piece of the real world into the image
of the piece of the real world which
happens to lie in a d-dimensional chart
well if unfortunately space time is four
dimensional you cannot print an atlas of
SpaceTime by printing on sheets of paper
you need to print on four dimensional
sheets of paper which mathematically you
can do practically you can't okay the
surface of the Earth is uh it's it's
lucky that it's two-dimensional right
okay so um this guy this map is called
the chart map because obviously you can
have the same domain in the real world
but you could choose different chart
maps represent them differently in your
Atlas but it must be continuous
okay um and now comes a really important
piece a Blackboard
please
um now comes an important piece namely
you see if a map goes from some subset
into Rd what does it mean to go to Rd I
cannot stop emphasizing Rd is just R
cross R cross R and so on is the set of
D tups they're just D numbers in an
order
okay how do I provide you with this
information well I can provide you how a
point in here how a point p in there is
mapped by X to an element in Rd well so
the result must be an
object with d entries is that right
clear so for any point here x of P the
image is an object M D
entries the each entry will depend on
what point you chose so you have a
number a real number X1 of p a real
number X2 of p and so on and real number
XD of P so what are the X's
where where x i the i x is a map that
takes a point in U of course and Maps it
only to R so not to
Rd but to a real number Nam the X2 of P
to a real number that's then here the
second element to a real number and this
you have for IAL 1 2 3 up to
D in other words a chart map that
Associates with each point D real
numbers is of course the same
information as giving you D many maps
called XI so x one is a totally
different map from X2
that take the points into
R okay these are the component Maps if
you wish the component maps and these
component
maps please yeah thank you these
component Maps they have a
name
call so if ux is a
chart thank you so if ux is a
chart then the maps X1 from from U to
R down to
XD of U to
R which is information that's equivalent
to the one Map X from U to Rd right
these guys are
called
the
coordinate
Maps
Okay so this the next piece of
terminology and of course what the co
okay so that's this and then we have if
p is a point in the chart domain in the
domain of a
chart
then X1 of p is the first
coordinate first
coordinate of the point
p with respect to the chosen
chart because if you choose another
chart of course that will be another
number X of p is the first coordinate so
X of P may be
one uh X of 2 of p is the
second coordinate of the point p p is
the foot of the Alpha Tower in the real
world X2 of p is what happens to be the
number on your public
chart where he puts in this direction
the foot of the Eiffel Tower in the
chart this is man-made charts are a
figment of our
imagination we imagine charts charts
have nothing to do with physics they may
be very useful an atlas is extremely
useful but nobody would say because a
publisher printed an atlas upside down
that it would be less comfortable to
live in that part of the
world an atlas is some something
imagined most of undergraduate physics
we formulate in atlases and we very much
confuse what is imagined and what is
real I will emphasize therefore very
often what is the real world and what is
an image an arbitrary image of it Ein it
took Einstein three years to clarify
this it takes us three days okay so
that's that's excellent good so but this
is a key point this is a key point and
it's totally obvious totally OB you noce
from lran mechanics you have a physical
system that moves on some configuration
space and you all learned that you can
choose generalized
coordinates that you can choose other
generalized
coordinates choosing coordinates is
choosing charts choosing different
charts is choosing different
coordinates does the bird that flies by
here care about my idea about charts no
the bird is not impressed what would be
physics let's not say a bird a bird has
this this uh this Free Will thing let's
take a stone a stone without free
will you throw a stone what would
physics be if your stone was
impressed by your thinking about a chart
one chart or the other it would be
physics with
telekinesis I could start moving things
by imagining different charts first is
call these frames of reference or
whatnot okay or generalized
coordinates if that comes up tomorrow if
somebody conducts an experiment and
we're sure okay the experiment proves by
thinking I can move things not a problem
we do chart dependent
physics but since that is not the case
all we do until further notice is we do
chart independent physics we'll very
much think about the real world the foot
of the Eiffel Tower is a real point that
is there has nothing to do with changing
coordinates changing coordinates doesn't
move the foot of the Eiffel Tower okay
we do physics without telekinesis that's
the
programmatic uh aim okay good so these
are the
coordinate uh the coordinates of a point
and the coordinate Maps Okay so I
already explained the foot of the Eiffel
Tower I don't need to do this again um I
will look at
quarter past we have until a quarter
past is that
right until when do we uh pardon me 12
until 12 okay perfect perfect okay um
so um let's make another
example so now take as the real world
the surface the points in R2 I should
already say surface the points in R2
it's all these these pairs and now we
look at the chart U just an example that
is all these points but I can remove the
element 0
0 by the way if I say m is the set
R2 a set
okay there is a piece of R2 and it
consists of the points um what is it if
the set
so this is a a little aside that's
important a set what's the difference
between the set one two and the set to
one none yeah okay I already wrote the
equal sign there's no difference a set
has no
order if I consider this as a set I can
rip it apart I can grind it I can make a
powder of this and I fill the powder in
a glass and then I shake the glass and
then I come to you and I pour the little
pile of powder there and and I say there
you got your
R2 we like to think of R2 as being
somehow this thing R2 is a powder
because R2 is a set now I can shake it
and I change all relations between the
points that we may imagine now I give it
a little more structure if I equip it
with the standard
topology then I can take this like a
rubber a uh piece of paper and I can
pull it and so on but I cannot rip it
apart because that would be
non-continuous okay so the R2 you're
thinking of usually at least is the
topological space R2 with the standard
topology but as a pure set it's a
powder okay okay that just as a warning
what is a set what's a topological space
a topological manif and so on and so
okay so anyway we take this as a
topological space we we take this set
and now I invent a chart uh and the
chart I invent is the following X needs
to go from U into
R2 uh and it's as follows R2 elements as
a set as a powder is nevertheless pairs
of numbers as a set and I map this to
now I'm because I feel like it to minus
M minus n because that's an element of
R2 I can do that
uh I arbitrarily took the z0 element out
so let me draw a picture of this so um
if you say this is the real world it's
the real Blackboard right the real
Blackboard is this it extends it's the
Blackboard I can touch it's the real
world but now I take the real Blackboard
and I only consider the real Blackboard
without a point which maybe the Z 0 and
I MA this to a chart now this is the
chart you have in your book it's a
picture of the Blackboard for instance
right and you map this and you see you
take this point to this point and you
take that point to this point and you
and so on and if you have here for
instance a point set that looks like
this um then you know that the map I
just produced takes it to here so this
would be what your publisher if you have
an atlas that is an atlas of the
Blackboard I took this point out for fun
uh and you want to represent this real
life situation namely the the chalk dust
that's here on the Blackboard you want
to draw it into your map you take your
chart Map X and every single point You
Take by the chart Map X to every single
point here and this is the image of your
real world it's a perfect chart map you
might say oh it inverts the real world
what do you mean it's a chart map it's
as good as any other chart map
okay um yes if you the black already
numbers of R2 you assume already that's
not the real world you have
already
yes yes in order to you're absolutely
right it's a notorious problem of of
emphasizing because the real world
doesn't consist of points the point is
what I would have to do is what I did in
the beginning I indicated a map by
really saying this element and this is
on the Blackboard I point with my finger
at it I take this one I assign this the
number minus 1 minus 2 okay if I do this
so it's more like these these arrows I I
drew before and what you need to do in
real life you need to go and you need to
put little
flags and you say here in the real world
there's a a flag it's here on the moon
and it's our flag and we call this 0.1
to uh that is putting up flags that have
numbers on them is inventing a chart and
that's what of course what gold diggers
do they put their claim and they draw
lines and you know stuff like this so
it's absolutely true and in fact I will
draw a diagram in a second in physics we
always ignore the real world we only
talk about charts and chart
representatives of the real world but at
least mathematically we should put it in
in order to know what we're talking
about Okay so
okay so so we can do it like this but we
can do another
chart another chart map on the same
domain we can do the following I can do
the points MN if you're happy with that
we already put up Flags here okay and I
can map it to square root of m^2 + n 2
AR tangent n / M if you think that's
crazy then you say polar coordinates are
crazy because now again I have the real
world and say in the real world on this
Blackboard the dust chalk that lies on
this
circle if I map the situation into a
chart on paper then now the first
coordinate in quotations Mark is the
distance from the
origin intuitively speaking well it's
just this algebraic expression and the
second one is an angle it takes with say
this axis roughly speaking so the chart
domain of the entire R2 of the entire R2
without the Z 0 element the entire chart
domain is this set here it runs here
only from 0 to 2 pi oh I need to take
out I'm sorry I take out the entire take
the slit plane here so I take out the
entire x axis so
without a z where a is in R so I not do
not only take out the point I could have
also done this here I take out this
entire slit for certain reasons don't
worry about it so
this pardon
me I don't
understand a is an
r ah yeah yeah thank you thank you an
plus r plus Z now we got it okay so
um so the chart domain is this infinite
half infinite strip because it ends
here that's the point I took the zero
out
without
only
zero a plus yeah yeah
sorry the negative ones are still in
here but I took out the zero as well
this is everything behind the I took it
out including the
zero I take the a the m0 I took it
out m equal Z is taken
out okay so this is the x or the Y let's
call this the map y this is the map y of
view of this real world and now please
draw the circle in the
map how does it look like yes
exactly the part of the circle that is
covered by this domain well this point
of course cannot belong to it because
it's not in U is this so we have a
perfect
chart and this is the image of the real
life
circle in this chart it looks like this
well this is what you call generalized
coordinates in classical mechanics you
would probably say oh this is the r
coordinate and this is the FI coordinate
but we call them the X1 of p and the X2
of P could call them the five of p and
and an R of P but this is just what it
is okay so again the same real world
situation of course here if you had the
circle it would appear as the circle you
just don't see that it's inverted like
the F
right that's it okay so any chart you
can come up with is covered by this
definition and in the chart things may
look very different from The Real World
you need to know how the charts are
related to the real world
okay
third section chart transition
Maps so these are objects that are only
they derived objects objects derived
from certain charts we already have so
they're actually not worth
mentioning but they're heavily used by
physicists hence we introduced
them imagine a situation or imagine two
two
charts
ux and VY so different domains and
different prescriptions of how to map
into a chart imagine two charts with
overlapping
regions so in the real world let's say
this is now the real world um there is
one chart domain U and another chart
domain V and they have a non-empty
overlap that is what I mean they're
overlapping the overlap is
nonempty now U comes with a chart map
that takes any point in
U to some pce of R2 or
Rd well in particular it takes a point
in the intersection there so I can take
a point in the intersection by the chart
Map X that comes with the U into a point
in some chart why well because the
intersection certainly is a part of U
now because that point lies in the
intersection I may use alternatively the
chart map that comes with the V region
because it obviously also lies in the v
region and I can alternatively map the
very same point in the real world the
foot of the Eiffel Tower the same point
in the real world I can map it into
another chart of course you will turn
the pages of your chart and your Eiffel
Tower will usually appear more than once
will be appear on that chart here and on
the other chart here because the charts
always have a little overlap in order
for you to navigate it will turn out
that we also need this overlap to
navigate okay
um so that means you can think about
after you say okay this x is defined on
all of you but you can certainly
restrict it to only U intersected V and
the Y map can also be restricted to U
intersected V now if you map the whole X
of U it would maybe look like this this
would be X of U but if you map only the
intersection that will be only that
part the same here if you map the whole
V by y it may be y of V but if you only
map the
intersection it will only be
maybe this part so this is X of U
intersected V and this guy here is y of
U intersected V I think the idea is
pretty clear now you have in chart on
the chart on page seven you have the
foot of the Eiffel Tower here in the
chart on page 28 you have the foot of
the I Tower here and one obvious
question is what if you have to turn
pages how can you can you directly take
the coordinates on page seven and
translate them in the coordinates on
page 28 that would be very useful
because here you use this putting up
flags on the surface of the Earth in
order to make this map this was exactly
gard's concern you already chose somehow
coordinates was just to quickly write
this down but you put need to put Maps
wouldn't it be great if I could just
take these Co coordinates and had a rule
how to translate them to those well it's
very simple this map X is invertible so
I can take the yellow Point
here and I can feed it into the inverse
of x x inverse takes me to the real foot
of the alha tower this is the foot of
the alha tower in the real world and
then I apply the Y map to
it and then I have the coordinates in
the other chart
well but this is nothing but y after X
inverse
applied to the representative of the
foot of the Alpha Tower in this
chart so this is the picture and you see
this uh requires uh artists skills um
it's clever to do this
formally U intersected v u uux and y v y
are charts you can map this by x to the
image of X U intersected V which is and
that's now a point I wish to emphasize
of course is an element of Rd um subset
of Rd you can take the entire subset so
this the entire subset You Take by y you
go to Y of u intered v subset of the
same not the same well of Rd forget the
same thing and now I con con construct a
map from this set to that set namely
from the Shaded set to the Shaded set
and that map is y after X
inverse and this
map y after X
inverse this guy
here this is
called the
chart transition
map and if physicists talk about a
change of coordinates or a change of
chart you know the coordinates are just
the component Maps the coordinate maps
are just the component maps of the chart
map if physicists talk about a change of
coordinates they go to one of their
favorite
imaginations and transform to another of
their favorite imagin
ations imaginations
nevertheless the real world sits up
here and because the chart maps are
invertible and in both directions
continuous the chart transition map is a
map from under gradate
analysis a part of Rd to another part of
Rd from an open part of Rd at that to
another open part of Rd and this will be
continuous because these guys are
continuous in both directions and the
composition of continuous Maps you
remember the end of last lecture is
continuous now as physicists changing
coord we start in one coordinate system
and we say let's start in the cartisian
coordinate system that's a good one well
it's it's just fantasy okay but you
start there and then you say oh but now
this problem is better to go to the
polar coordinate system and so on you
just moving back and forth here and
there and what you never touch as a
mathematical object is the real world
you never use the foot of the Eiffel
Tower you only take your coordinates of
the foot of the Eiffel Tower now this is
fair enough and of course it's correct
in what you predict mechanics everything
is fine but it can lead you to the
philosophical problem of somehow
imagining that there is some reality to
the coordinates of the foot of the
Eiffel Tower and even if you understood
you can choose other coordinates you
might hold the position that well the
cesan coordinates those are the real
coordinates and hence we don't call them
generalized coordinates and the other
coordinates they're kind of not so real
as the other this means nothing okay so
these are all just Notions you invent
because the theory is usually presented
within
this uh yellow
box one of the advantages of looking at
this manifold picture is you can
calculate very nicely here but please do
not forget that there's the real world
you want to talk about and the foot of
the Eiffel Tower is the point p in here
and it doesn't care about whether you
look at this chart map or that chart map
and this needs this is something that
took Einstein three years to fully
understand he understood it half or 34s
or
99% and that's wrong okay you need to
understand it 100% And this manifold
picture gives you this 100% that's the
chart transition
map aha now the chart transition Maps
they contain this fantastic information
so you have a chart say you have an
atlas that has many
pages and on these Pages there say some
continent that looks like this and some
that looks like this now on
another
uh chart there is a continent like this
and there's something like this and so
on and of course you realize oh this one
is actually the same part is this one
and the chart transition Maps here these
guys will actually say oh here uh I
don't know what this is uh oh dear
Madrid Madrid is again to be found here
so there needs to be a chart transition
map from here to here that's this the
chart transition map contains the
information so this is informally but
it's a good way to think about it
contains the instructions is better
contains the
instructions
how to glue together how to glue
together the charts of an
atlas imagine you're the captain of a
ship and these modern ships you can sit
deep down in the ship you have no
windows no nothing and it's it's a long
cruise and you have nothing to do you
have an atlas of the world with you and
you're very desperate and it's a
single-sided
Atlas okay single page one one side on
one page and you you're very frustrated
no women there whatever and you pull out
the
charts because they so frustrated and
then you have some glue and you decide
to glue together the charts in their
overlap regions which you can clearly
identify like in the street Atlas you
glue what do you get if you glue them
all
together you get a paper model of
the sphere you get a sphere if you glue
them all together topologically speaking
well if the charts are small enough it
looks a little bit Wiggly but you
essentially get a sphere and all you
used is the information this part looks
like this part green continent green
continent glued together here like this
you get the sphere and what you did is
just you identified this point in this
chart with the corresponding point there
and glued them together it's a gluing
instruction which point with which point
you may have to bend the paper a little
and so on and then you get a sphere
in the tutorial today you'll have also
charts of a world and you need to glue
them together and they look like now
normal charts but you will be surprised
what you get out when you glue them
together it's the chart transition maps
that you can have all the information
about the real world globally
topologically in the chart transition
Maps hence they're so beloved by
physicists it's very good information
with a data structure Rd to Rd which is
very simple to implement
mathematically but the meaning of it is
only what you glue together nobody would
say if you have an atlas you understood
that the world is a a sphere the surface
of the Earth is a sphere unless you
start gluing together
okay okay so uh those are the chart
transition Maps now we come to a very
important Point uh I call it a a
Blackboard
please uh it's
so the headline is manifold
philosophy what is the whole philosophy
of writing down
manifolds now the full extent to this of
this we will only understand once we
start discussing differentiability of
Curves and functions so far we only talk
about continuity no jumps but
differentiability of a curve means
there's everywhere a tangent roughly
speaking okay the full extent we'll only
understand there but the basic idea is
the following I have the real world and
I can rep if I have an atlas I can
represent the real world in charts for
instance I have the course of a ship in
the real world so the bubbles it leaves
in the sea when it moves these points in
the real world I can represent them by
drawing them in a chart that's what
Navigators do they put the cuse in their
charts and thereby they represent what
the ship in the real world did now the
Navigator puts the cause of the ship in
a chart would the Navigator be surprised
or his supervisor at home if all of a
sudden the course of the ship would jump
to another point and continue from there
or he would be very much surprised would
say how did you do that how did you do
that but what is the argument that this
supervisor would have to give why this
is unusual well he would have to argue
that the chart maps from the the real
world into the chart are bjective and
continuous that in the charts you've
chose the standard topology blo bloop
blop so he would to have to argue from
there that a discontinuity of the curve
in the chart which is a curve from the
real numbers the curve parameter into R2
this is what we teach undergraduate
students a a point particle is given by
a curve in R3 or in R2 but this is just
in the chart so we shouldn't think of
the Curve curve of R in R3 as the real
curve in the real world it's the image
of the curve in a chart you
chose right that's this but because of
the postulated continuity or the
constructed continuity you would indeed
be able to judge the continuity of the
curve in the real world from the
continuity in the chart right so what
you can do instead of defining
continuity directly in the real world
which you can because the real world is
a topological space and you can Define
continuity of Curves you could instead
and that's the manifold philosophy push
the objects you want to study the Real
World objects push them down into the
charts look at the chart Representatives
using the chart maps study the objects
in the charts which is very simple
because these are curves from R to R2 or
their functions from R2 to R like a
tempor tempure distribution drawn in a
chart these are objects you know from
undergraduate analysis you study them
there and then you get the idea couldn't
we define properties of objects in the
real world by properties that our chart
Representatives
have right and the answer is yes you can
but you got to be careful so that's
fourth manifold
philosophy
often it is
desirable or in Brackets or indeed the
only
way and we will see examples for this or
in indeed the only way
to
define
properties
and now I give examples in Brackets but
of course we will have more examples
like
continuity of Real World
objects for instance a
curve in the real world a curve gamma
from R to m is a curve in the real
world by
um
judging
suitable
conditions not on the object
itself not on the real world
object
itself
but on
a chart
representative or image I make this
clear in a second in an example on a
chart representative of that real world
object the advantage of such an approach
is obvious or the advantages the
advantages are that in a chart let's do
this for the example of a curve real
world course of the ship in the real
world is a curve
gamma from some parameter set into
M and now I choose a chart
U and I look at that portion of the
curve that lies in the chart U so we
look at that portion of the curve that
makes the argument simpler but you can
generalize
this and you map this
curve into a chart so this is is the
image of the U part this is X of U and
this Curve will in this chart maybe look
like this and this is
X this is um X after gamma why well
let's draw it here the U comes with an X
chart into X of U lies in Rd and then
you can look instead of looking at the
curve in the real world you can look at
this object here which is X after gamma
so you first execute gamma and then X
and this is of course the curve in the
chart because it goes from a real
parameter to a part of
R2 this is what you're told in
undergraduate physics this is what you
say is the trajectory for instance of a
particle in R3 or something like this
but you see in fact it's only the chart
representative of this the curve in the
real world is this object up here okay
but now of course you're instructed in
underg gradiate physics to
say this is the trajectory of the
particle and it must be continuous so
what you really say is if this chge
representative is continuous which you
know by undergraduate analysis what it
means R to Rd
continuous if this is continuous then
you say the particle path which is in
the real world is continuous so you do
precisely this by ccid
assumption you you you do this you say
you judge you define the property like
continuity of a real world object the
real path of the real ship in the real
world by judging suitable conditions in
this case you also call it continuity
you call it undergraduate continuity not
on the real world object but on the
chart representative of it it's an
advantage because you can use
undergraduate analysis in
charts uh mathematics in charts is
mathematics on the real numbers it's not
so complicated it's a good thing but it
has a
disadvantage it has a philosophical
disadvantage which I already mentioned
the philosophical disadvantage is you
might start confusing what is a chart
image which what is the real world
object assuming you Einstein and you
spend three years thinking about it and
you no longer fall into that trap
there's yet another disadvantage
the notion you define down here by
referring to the Chart representation
may be ill defined what does that mean
what's ill definition a definition says
this and this is defined like so and so
but here we want to assign a property to
this object gamma but we judge it by the
object X after gamma where X is a
figment of our
imagination so we imagine something with
certain conditions okay and we say well
including my fantasy I afford
here I assign a property to this object
which has nothing to do with the fantasy
whatsoever the bird doesn't care about
my imagined chart so how nuts may it be
it can be very nuts to take the
composite object including my fantasy my
superstition could call it and judge the
path of the bird and assign the path of
the real bird a property that also
depends on my thinking that is very
dangerous unless I
ensure that if I have any other
thinking the result doesn't change need
so maybe IL
defined defined um to avoid
that maybe IL defined
because
um an arbitrarily chosen chart
arbitrarily
chosen
chart is
employed we need to make
sure that
property uh that the defined
property does not
change if we
afford
another
fantasy well the fantasy is another
chart because that's just something I'm
I'm thinking about okay so um formally
it's a very simple idea I have a curve I
take do it for a curve I could do it for
a function on a domain for anything okay
I take a curve and I say so now
fantasies will be in in in red fantasies
are well this is at least a part of the
real world but what is a real fantasy is
this chart map how this part is mapped
this is here and uh so we have the
composite map uh that consists of a
little bit of fantasy well of arbitrary
choice of superstition together with
something in the real world now I look
at this object and I say whatever
properties this has say continuity I
then call continuity of this guy here
that may be a problem unless you ensure
that another fantasy so sorry fantasies
are in color uh another fantasy is the
yellow fantasy another chart goes to Y
of
U and then you have another
representative gamma no uh y after gamma
y after gamma again an object that uses
some fantasy but if you can ensure that
if in some chart some property holds if
you can ensure it holds in any other
chart too for any other fantasy then
it's obviously independent of your
choice of
fantasy so you may use fantasy if you
ensure that it's independent of fantasy
you know this maybe from equivalence
relations if you define the sum say
uh you define an operation on
equivalence classes and you define it by
using representatives of each class but
you need to make sure it's independent
of the representative chosen because
choice of a representative is a pick you
make arbitrarily and so on okay so how
can we insure for say continuity I say
okay this continuous I can check because
it goes from R to a subset of Rd both
equipped with the standard topology
under graded
analysis assume I know this is
continuous can I already conclude that
with respect to any other chart it's
also
continuous yes I can because this map
here this map here can of is of course
the same one as if I go down
here and then by here to here so in
other words y after gamma that's this
one can be written as
um y after X
backwards
after X after
gamma so this just looking at this
diagram but because the composition is
associative it's y after X inverse after
X after gamma I can ah you only inserted
the
identity okay you can think of this like
that algebraically but you can think of
it in this way whatever way you think
about it you see ah of course I have
here this chart transition map why after
X inverse we know that those are
continuous we argued this before we know
that X after gamma is continuous that
was our starting assumption but then the
composition of continuous Maps is
continuous ah so for the notion of
continuity of this curve from R to Rd
the continuity of the chart trans ition
map saved the day the continuity of the
chart chart transition map makes this
chart dependent definition fantasy
independent or Choice independent I
emphasize fantasy to to be poic but it
makes it independent of the choice of
chart now imagine something different
imagine you came you got the idea that
undergraduate physicist lecturers get to
Define
X after gamma which after all is a map
from R into Rd they say let's check
whether this is a differentiable map
whether we can find the derivative of
this map which at a point you would call
the velocity of the curve or something
but we're in a chart now let's say you
define you say if this is
differentiable as a map from R to Rd
let's say you want to say then you
define
the curve gamma in the real world you
call that
differentiable no obviously you can't
decide this immediately because from R
into some set with a topology you don't
have enough structure for instance you
can't do sums and uh uh subtractions and
divisions which you need for a
differential quotient right you need a
difference and the division so
additional multiplication roughly
speaking in order to you you cannot
Define differentiability at the manifold
level you could with continuity and you
could push it and you all we did before
you could have decided at the manifold
level or at the chart level but now if
you go to differentiability which we
will do in the second next lecture you
can only talk about the chart
Representatives because here from R to
Rd you can establish an addition and you
can establish a multiplication with
scalers in order to do differential
quotient but now imagine you did this
could you still say if I know that this
here is differentiable you can check
this this is not a problem you can check
whether this is
differentiable but are you guaranteed
that this one is then differentiable too
so it's independent of your chart choice
no you can't because this chart
transition map
here y after X inverse we only
guaranteed that it is
continuous but if you have a
differentiable function and you compose
it with A continuous function it may be
that the result is only
continuous but not differentiable
because the chart transition map can
introduce into a nice smooth
curve a little Edge that still continues
to do something like this but it's no
longer differentiable you have no unique
tangent so you see oh my God on a
topological manifold with its Contin
chart transition Maps we cannot Define a
notion of differentiability by defining
it in the
charts but in the charts is our only
possibility and we would like to have a
way to lift this notion in the chart to
here such for any other chart oh where
do the charts come from they come from a
big Atlas what if we take a huge Atlas
with lots of topological charts with
continuous transition functions and we
rip off page seven page
113 and Page
1080 because those were the ones that
had only continuous transition functions
from RD to RT Rd but transition
functions that were not
differentiable if you take out all the
troublemaking
charts then all of a sudden you have a
restricted Atlas an artificially
restricted Atlas however if you agree to
take charts only from the restricted
Atlas all the transition functions are
smooth you have composition or
differentiable you have composition of
differentiable maps which are again
differentiable and you lost of you got
rid of your problem one second but now I
give you for Christmas a maximal atlas
what's a maximal atlas an at maximal
topological Atlas is one that contains
every chart it could possibly contain
lots of redundancy it's the maximum
atlas of to topological space now by
having to rip out page number n n Prime
and triple prime and so on I give you
information because I could encode a
message in that right number seven
number 13 so on is the numbers of the in
the alphabet you know I could send you a
message I love you or something okay
ripping out charts is
information so reducing a maximal atlas
by ripping out certain charts that make
trouble for the Notions we want to
Define means providing information
and this additional information is
called the prescription of a
differentiable atlas and that will be
the second next lecture we'll do that
and then we'll make the
differentiability
work and that's a major step in
understanding SpaceTime please I'd like
to come back to that I'm one of those
happy physicist who don't care about
mathematical River at all but presently
since you forced me to think
that perfect
this type of proof normally but we only
prove that if we have one
CH uh that we can conclude for any other
CH we how I'm still missing the step how
can we prove that uh the continuity
because we have defined continuity in a
precise way yes in your first lecture
please step yes um that's right so this
I would call
our continuity I called it undergraduate
continuity this one was the continuity
we defined um what the only thing I
showed so far and it's a very valid and
important observation the only thing I
showed so far is that my idea of R
continuity gives some notion of R
continuity on the gamma I could call it
the lifted R continuity that it has to
do with the continuity we were talking
about before hasn't been proven yet by
this but it can be proven very simply
because as much as if I know that if G
uh so if I have a map uh there it is
gamma uh
r
u r d roughly speaking X gamma I know if
this is continuous and this is
continuous I can conclude that this is
continuous but what you asking for is if
you know that this is continuous and
that is R continuous can you prove from
these two that this is continuous in the
original sense and the answer is yes you
can it's a few lines so indeed I because
with differentiability it's it's an an
accident of topology that I can decide
it at this level in the first place
hence I deemphasize this point whereas
differentiability I have no
differentiability at the manifold level
to compare with that's the question you
ask how does it compare to the original
notion of continuity but for other
Notions I do not even have something to
compare with and then you're thrown back
to the manifold and to the Chart picture
and then well definition is all you uh
that remains to be cared of thank
you yes you need the assumption that
it's invertible and the inverse is
continuous as well um in here
you
[Music]
um I'm not
sure could could be let me think about
it it could be that you're right that
you need the Inver the continuity of the
inverse as well in order to to do the
the red implication Arrow it could be I
I think not but I'm not sure simple we
do this in the break
okay please another
question
okay if there are no further questions I
invite you to the tutorials at 2:00 yes